New York Exodus to pro-business Florida
is a hot Trend that won't simmer down
anytime soon okay this is a fox business
story thousands of Americans have moved
from New York to Florida during the
pandemic to escape high taxes and crime
rates the trend has continued with 10
000 New Yorkers already leaving the
state in the first quarter of 2023. this
year folks not last year okay this is
written by Jenna an associate at
Sotheby's International Realty Florida's
Chief Financial Officer Jimmy Petronas
said that 900 new residents move to the
state every day from the state such as
New York jersey and Illinois 900 a day
that's 27 000 a month Florida is proving
attractive to home buyers because of its
lower taxes and pro-business environment
democrat-led States including California
Illinois New York saw the biggest
decline in population while being home
to some of the highest tax burdens in
the U.S
yeah I mean the Secret's out I I I've
been experiencing this for two decades
now about New Yorkers coming down for
New Year's coming down for vacation
coming down to have a great weekend here
and I would always ask them I'm like
what would it take for you to move to
Florida like ah no the Florida's like
you know vacation come in the winter
this ain't for me I don't know it's a
and now we're starting to see they're
like no no I'm here I'm here real good
now Secrets out whether that's because
of covid and all the lockdowns because
of that because of the low taxes
business friendly DeSantis mayor Suarez
down in Miami he's been a major element
of this and here's what I always tell
New Yorkers kind of like what Pat was
saying about their grit their grind
their hustle their stick to itness it's
like if you keep that attitude that you
that led you to have success in New York
in freaking Miami where they're running
a Cuban time and they just like
everything's going like you're gonna run
circles around the people here and
they're doing it so yeah you'll own the
city I mean listen the DNA doesn't leave
you the DNA of a fighter that goes to
any place like I remember one time I
came to Florida and I was speaking at
this uh Deerfield office and they said
well Patrick you can all you have to
sales people showed up to the meeting
late I said guys what the hell was this
all about
and they said oh Patrick We're on floor
at a time I said I don't give a
what time you're on okay if you ain't on
time close the door and get out no no
that's not how it's ran in Florida if
I'm running this meeting get out so like
are you serious I said yes I said come
here with me open up the uh what do you
call it the um not the blinds the glass
the drape whatever the drapes is on the
window yeah and I opened it up I said
look outside the window I said how many
buildings you see out there
I said count them they're like you
seriously want us account I said you get
the point how many buildings you see out
there hundreds okay who built those
buildings did somebody build those
buildings that came in late at 11
o'clock
how how much work did it take to build
those assets so don't give me the
about there's floor at a time no those
buildings were built by Killers and
somebody paid millions of dollars to buy
those buildings killers are in every
city it's just you guys are not The
Killers right now and you're lazy and
you're tired and you're buying this
excuse you take a killer from LA to New
York to Iowa to Boise to Wyoming even to
Chas Washington outside of Portland
that's no longer exists they're going to
whoop some ass and Lead leaders lead
everywhere they go so the New York DNA
Florida saying come on down here wasn't
the census given five thousand dollar
bonuses for cops to come down here yeah
yep see what's giving them out right
yeah they were coming good for you of
course and this is not going to slow
down by the way Tom any thoughts on this
I I think
I got like five thoughts on it and then
the first is I I think what you're
seeing in here I mean good grief
unemployment two and a half percent you
know in the two and a half or two point
six percent pick a city in Florida major
ones Jacksonville Orlando Jacksonville
is actually the biggest city in Florida
by the way not Miami uh support
Port City they had a Super Bowl there
they got an NFL team there there's a lot
going on up there and you take a look we
got 2.5 unemployment and you put a
playing field in place you put a canvas
in place like you know the leaders in
Florida and there's a lot of credits
given to DeSantis well deserved but you
know what there's also what mayor Suarez
is doing when leaders put a canvas in in
place that attracts people they come and
paint beautiful pictures and that's what
you're seeing here people are coming
down here and you know what I like it
that you know why Florida is going to be
safer because I like a few New York cops
down here I want New York cops to be on
the police force down here I want them
to be happy and then I want their
attitude I want their their focus I
don't want them to be laid back I love
what's Happening Here we had a guy came
here so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]